we have a crisis of participation and I
got to tell you guys I went to a Donald
Trump rally a couple nights ago never
been to one I thought this video was
really interesting so there's this guy
Dean Phillips who's a congressman in
Minnesota who is running as a Democrat
and uh he's quickly realizing kind of
like RFK Jr realized that the Democrats
are complete lunatics he had a rally
couple days ago I think this is from two
days ago and it was near a trump rally
and he wandered in Democrat running for
president learning what the DNC is all
about and how corrupt they are decides
to wander into a trump rally check this
out we have a crisis of participation
and I got to tell you guys I went to a
Donald Trump rally a couple nights ago
never been to one uh I had an event
across the street I saw the line of
people waiting in the cold for hours and
I thought what the heck you know I'm
going to be a leader who actually
invites people doesn't condemn them met
probably 50 Trump people waiting in line
every single one of them thoughtful
hospitable friendly all of them so
frustrated that they feel nobody's
listening to them but Donald Trump a
diverse crowd people who had never been
to a trump event before my party is
completely delusional right now Sarah
that is exactly what happened to me when
I was on the fence about Trump I was
driving through Los Angeles on Wilshire
Boulevard and there was a trump rally
and I was like you know what let me just
go and see what happens and it was a
joyous festival with American flags and
Latinos for Trump and gays for Trump and
blacks for Trump and everybody was happy
and nice um I've also I said once to
Bill Mar podcast that he would be
welcomed more at a trump rally than if
he went to a progressive rally like an
AOC rally and he even agreed with me uh
I suppose none of this surprises you
yeah no of course not and I I mean I
want to add to Michael's point about the
Suburban moms because of course I think
their votes very much are still in play
um and here is why I understand your
point about they're not going to want to
vote for a felon and I agree with you
but there is the unprecedented basis of
but we all know he's not not actually a
like they're weaponizing the system
against him to call him a felon so that
they can say see you don't want this
felon to be your president and so you
know I mean you're working with the
other side who is just operating to try
to um I'm I'm trying are we on YouTube
we are but say say whatever you want
we're on Rumble and locals you're good
you know there's a lot of procedures
that are happening um to children that
the Biden Administration is pushing for
you know you're living at a time where
parents are getting their their right
taken from them if they don't affirm
their child's gender and so I do think
that there is a lot that is still in
play another issue that I think is still
in play is the minority vote uh Dave you
pointed out Latinos for Trump and blacks
for Trump and all of that and I saw a
tweet from the raer Meek Mills not that
long ago and he retweeted a trump the
vake clip where they were you know they
were at some rally and they were talking
and he retweeted it and and he said you
guys are going to be real surprised when
you find out who black people in poverty
are voting for this time around now am I
putting a whole lot of stake in that no
because historically black people should
have started voting against Democrats a
very long time ago but I do think that
it it may take this Rock Bottom
Administration for these people to wake
up and say you know finally we've been
fooled and I don't just mean black
people I mean the Suburban moms as well
I mean these are these are un Uncharted
territories this is an unprecedented
time that we are in and that's why I
wonder if the Suburban mom vote
is still in play because I look at this
and I'm like no freaking way my I want
my kids to go through another four years
of this Administration I will vote for
anything else malice is is the rub
though on that that everything I agree
with everything Sarah just said right
there with with the kids in the Border
like parents are waking up to all of
this nonsense but that sliver of people
that we talking about that white
Suburban Woman They we just know they
have a massive aversion to Trump and
they're the ones also who have Munch
ains by proxy who are for the stuff with
the gender with their kids so they are
the Swing Vote so Sarah's completely
correct like you can you can see a lot
of them are going to be you know
anti-trump a lot of them are going to be
for Trump you know blah blah blah so
they're they're they're the ones who are
going to decide this election unless
it's a landslide one way or another
which I can easily see happening uh uh
as well but I'm just going to tweak
Sarah a little bit this is not the
there's a joke Reagan used to make how
uh he was there's two people walking in
Soviet Union red square and one them
goes to the other is this it have we
reached full communism and the other
goes oh no it gets much worse so for you
to say this is Rock Bottom I know you're
not disagree with me it can get a lot
worse I agree I agree you're right I
just my point is my point is I I feel
like there are a lot of Americans that
are frustrated like I am that say you're
right to your point Michael that like
we're not at rock bottom but like what
the hell happens if he gets another four
years